I think what's interesting is I i worked
with celebrities for so long and you
know celebrities really create the
persona that they want the public to see
them as and I kind of working around
that promise myself that no matter what
if the camera was rolling or if I was in
front of the camera that I would be
myself no matter you know that I would
reveal whatever it is that I was feeling
and I don't know why people it's so
taboo to talk about depression or
feeling isolated or feeling disconnected
it's almost like people want to try to
portray themselves as being perfect and
happy and everything's great but that's
not real life and that doesn't make a
real documentary you know so that that
really gave me a lot of like courage to
be able to want to go out and make this
so that I could be real and you said
that there were people in the industry
that encouraged you not to talk about
depression and isolation and suicide and
I'm wondering why do you think that is
why I mean I understand that some people
look at that in terms of menlo that's
weak but you said that maybe people
would think that
were able to then work on a project
remember somehow label you a certain way
yeah I think that I can understand the
business side of of making films and you
know it's a lot of money and it's a lot
of people's money and my lawyer my agent
both felt like me talking about
addiction suicide depression anxiety
talking about that in the public and
that it would hurt my career that I
would you know not be able to be insured
or hired and I didn't agree with them I
didn't agree because I felt like this
journey was about me getting better this
journey was about meeting these people
and showing that when you have
face-to-face interaction and you come
with an open heart that we help each
other we help each other grow we'd help
each other get through things so you
know I I sort of went the exact opposite
of what they told me to do and I'm so
glad that I did and I no longer work
with them haha I find it interesting
that that would be said when so many
people in this town
in this business struggle with those
exact same things and maybe they can't
be vocal about it but through seeing
something it might help them what kind
of feedback did you get from last
night's screening last night screening
was the best screening have ever had of
anything I've ever done because you know
there were so many tears and so much
laughter and it just felt like people
really understood my journey and what I
went through like they related to it and
so many people came up to me and said
you know I suffered from this and this
gives me hope that I can get through it
and that's what that's why I made it you
know I mean yeah I made it to go and
document a personal journey but I
thought in some way that if I could make
it through this depression if I could
find my artistic integrity again that
maybe it would inspire other people to
be able to do that too and to have the
courage to be able to get out there and
tell their stories no matter who says
that they shouldn't so where are you
right now
in terms of like here you've put this
incredibly personal story out that some
people are trying to say hey you know
what maybe you should skew it a little
bit so that it sounds a little rosier
mm-hmm so how is it for you to share
this with everybody I realize this is
still new in terms of everybody see
mm-hmm but we how is that is it is it a
little scary or you feel free in terms
of hey I can just be me and I don't have
to put on sort of an act I feel ya i
feel i feel very free to be Who I am and
that makes me feel free to be an artist
and to create organically the way that I
want to create and not have to have like
this set formula that I feel like
Hollywood kind of feeds you and makes
you think that you need so I feel great
I mean I feel like I'm you know I went
through such a hard year and this
project was really tough but now I'm at
a place where I finally get to do the
work that I want to do and I set that
bar for myself by saying you know what
I'm not going to conform and do it the
way that you want me to do it I'm gonna
do it the way I want to do it as an
artist and it's just you know setting
the tone now for the rest of my work the
rest of my this things that I want to do
you